it's jessica capshaw
by the way my intro should have been
okay someone's about to come here
whose father basically is the
only father figure i've ever known in my
life and we've known each other since we
were what was how old were we
oh i want i want to say seven
seven or eight i remember
um when i went to visit okay so
her the man we're talking about is
steven spielberg and her mom is kate
capshaw
and i remember going to like the temple
of doomsat
in london i i remember that too and
i feel like you and i had parallel um
experiences in that
we learned so young that a the hair and
makeup trailer was where all the fun
stuff happened
yeah and that you could
transform and then all of a sudden you
would be in this different world and
this world was
rich with all this story and excitement
and there was something that just felt
so like
thrilling about every minute um i
remember
one time when we used to talk about how
weekends on with your kids was like
more exhausting than like a day at work
you know and i i didn't understand that
and now i understand it so much
you're you're so right yeah well there's
two parts of that right there's like
the the dirty little secret which is
that
um i would shamelessly accept so many
compliments on how
winningly i was managing four children
and a job and how did i do that and how
did i
balance everything and i would think
dirty little secret
going to work is easy
going to work is filling up my cup it's
making me feel creative
quite frankly i don't have to get anyone
anything to drink or eat while i'm there
and then the number two was that i
couldn't believe that people actually
were would be hopefully expected about
the weekend when
those were my two hardest days how do
you find an
end with talking to your kids where do
you find the balance of like
truth where do you want to put bumper
rails in
how do you talk to your kids like in
general but of course this week
yeah um well i think uh
jumping off point because i know you and
i i share her
and i think she's just such an
incredible resource i think that um miss
pressman and her
podcast is sort of unbelievable well and
dr eliza
is on this show earlier so yeah i feel
like she operates from a very
um neutral position of meeting your kids
where they're at right so i have a
four-year-old an eight-year-old a 10
year old a 13 year old
it's not the same conversation it's a
different kind of conversation what i
get back from my kids is how much
they're looking
at the friction they're looking at
like when people disagree how do they
handle it and they
and kids want to make it really simple
they want to make you know they want to
make
one thing good and one thing bad for the
past you know weeks it's just been such
a fever pitch of
of you know someone supporting this this
campaign someone supporting that
campaign and i've been trying
really really hard to to role model
that that the differences are okay
as long as you can talk about them um
but it's tough
it's really tough right now i was
interested because you've always been
that person who was like
yep raising kids is really hard you'll
find work days actually much easier and
simpler or
this or that and you've been right about
so many of those things
well but i mean i also just i feel like
the thing about that
is that again in the in the in the
balance
column of life where people sort of go
how do you balance i always think well
it's never a balance uh on one day i
could be a phenomenal
mother but i could be a really crappy
actress and vice versa i might have a
day where i'm an incredible
actress and i'm so like i'm feeling all
the wonderful things that come from it
but
i missed you know x y or z when it comes
to the kids and i think
that the the self-care that i think so
many people talk about
especially in these times is really
about um
figuring out how to be kind to yourself
the way that you worded that was just so
perfect and you mentioned
miss pressman who's dr elisa pressman
uh who is a very important friend of the
show
uh we have a segment with her called ask
alisa and you can go on our website to
learn more about
her and raising good humans it's all
there
and you know you're a very sane person
like
i don't know if you feel crazy elsewhere
but when i talk to you i it's like
man i'm just going yeah everything she
said it's
and i just was in you know the dressing
room here going
i didn't get to research that thing i
feel like the worst at my job
but i know i leaned in with my kids and
gave them the best halloween
i could ever have given them and it was
so special and such a great memory
but that gives me goosebumps like i have
goosebumps because
that that's the point is that this this
idea that we can all be great at
everything is a complete myth
it's just it's it's actually not
sustainable
you cannot you will burn out and you'll
become someone who you don't even
recognize anymore
and i think also i'm noticing i mean
again
i've you know the 4 8 10 13 year old i
cannot explain how
much i have been saying recently how
elemental failure is to success because
this needs to be understood out of
all the auditions i've ever gone on in
my life
i guesstimate that i have gotten the
part
point zero two percent of the time
wow that's that's like i fail mostly
and and yet i have an incredible life
and i feel super full because the piece
that i did
that i did get and that i do get is so
fulfilling and i don't need to be
perfect i don't need to be a hundred
percent
because sometimes point zero two percent
makes for an incredible life
see i am so glad this is why i love
this job is just to sit down in this
chair
and and have you have the floor
really and um i just love discussing
life with you
this was such a beautiful conversation
on this
most important day thank you any time
thank you jessica watch holidays on
netflix
i love you i'll be texting you in a
little bit